a friendly reminder that in three
generations everyone who knew us will be
dead including the people whose opinions
stopped you from doing what you wanted
all along imagine that someone you know
achieves every dream and hits every goal
they have years later they get old and
die two years after that how much do you
care about as much as everyone else will
if you accomplish your goals and dreams
do it for you
so I think about death all the time
because it's probably the central theme
it's probably the thing that I think the
most about and I think that influences
how I see time and also how I think how
it influences agency like what actions
I'm willing to take despite the Judgment
of others and so a lot of times it might
be because I have more insecurity than
everyone that I think like man I want to
do this thing and then I hear all these
other voices of reasons why I shouldn't
do it or why somebody else will say like
that's bad or you're bad or like that's
wrong whatever
and so I think I've had to come up with
a lot of these devices to get around my
own insecurities to take action despite
those insecurities and the biggest one
that I think about is that
it doesn't matter whether I achieve all
of my goals or I don't achieve a lot of
the goals in three generations I'll be
forgotten and the only people who were
nacing against me will also be dead
and so then it's like
just do it for me and then
when I wake up every day
there's only one voice I have to listen
to
but that means that you need to be able
to work out what to do from first
principles you now no longer have
societal Norms or assistance or Role
Models or archetypes or expectations and
that's also difficult in a different way
I think that the more you Flex whatever
that muscle is of like independent
thinking the more it becomes the default
way that you think and then everyone
else's action is to start looking more
and more insane to you
what like what's an example of that you
can think of I mean shoot
just the most basic ones of like living
the life that you don't want not wearing
what you want to wear not dating who you
want to date
um not living where you want to live
like you're living at home and you want
to move and your parents say no and you
don't make the move or you're digging a
girl because she's socially accepted you
know by your friend group she's safe but
like there's always some distance in
between you but you're like I don't want
to risk it right or like you're in the
the job and every day you go there and
you're like I mean it's okay and the
idea of just living in okay life just
sounds so terrifying to me that the
freedom to fail over and over again is
still more fulfilling to me at least it
feels like it's real
than walking through kind of on
autopilot and so I think that's a lot of
the choices that other people make that
seem insane to me now but didn't didn't
seem insane to me a decade ago you know
what I mean I think it's just like as
you practice
taking more agency taking more
responsibility for the decisions then
you just get better and better at it and
then it just seems more and more
ridiculous you're like they're like I
just can't quit my job and you're like
why
like no physically why like why can't
you quit your job like like you know I
mean they start hyperventilating it's
like you could could you move in with
your parents could you move in with a
friend could you split rent I mean I
could but I mean
other people who are gonna die in a
hundred years would think what
and one of my favorite ones is um
and I say this all the time to Layla
like whenever we're getting to some sort
of like mini complaint it's like you
know if you zoom out far enough you
can't see the Earth so we're talking
about like oh man they're gonna mess up
this order on this vendors like you know
if you zoom out far enough you can't see
the Earth
it's just like it just puts everything
immediately into perspective of how
ridiculous some of the things that we're
concerned about are Sean puri's got this
thing where he says don't follow what
most people do because you don't want
the results that most people get the
average person is obese likely to be
divorced and has less than 1K in the
bank it feels safe to do what everyone
else is doing but it's actually a
terrible decision
it's like the best way to guarantee to
not have the life that you want is to do
what everyone else is doing
unless you want what everyone else has
with no one which no one does
yeah it's um
being able to
think for yourself and and treating it
like a muscle I think is a smart way to
consider it because in the beginning
it's really really hard you've been
resting on societal norms and the way
you've dealt with past trauma and your
parents expectations and what all of
your friends do and what's accepted and
all of this stuff for so long
that when it first comes to you needing
to step on that muscle it's like trying
to move your ears like all humans have
got muscles that can move their ears but
because no one works it as a child
they're just atrophy away uh and this is
the ear muscle of personal growth
I think I had a lot of practice with it
because I had a so like a lot of people
have many voices that they hear that
they feel are judging them right they
have their friends they have their uncle
they have their siblings they have their
cousins co-workers whatever I think I
had just one voice that I heard really
loudly and I was trying I was talking to
one of our one of our employees the
other day and I was trying to put it in
perspective younger guy and I was like
I imagine how much you care about your
mother's opinion and your father's
opinion and your ship and all of those
other people I was like and now imagine
that there's literally only one because
I had no siblings I basically had no
mother
I had just a father
and so like his approval was literally
everything and he disapproved of the
path that I wanted to take in my life
and so I think a lot of these mental
faculties are these little Frameworks or
these isms just came from like
how can I combat this incredibly booming
voice in the background because like
when I look at what I was doing at the
time like I was a consultant you know I
graduated in three years I took the
consulting job I did all the things but
the craziest thing was that the moment
that my father was most proud of me and
he approved of my life the most was when
I was the saddest
and so that's when I was like maybe his
approval isn't the right way to feel
good about life
and so that that started basically the
six month journey of from when I decided
that I wanted to change my life until
when I changed it and I think that like
as you become more able or more potent
or higher agency that timeline between
when you decide you want to do something
and when you actually do it just
continues to compress right like now if
I want to change something I'm like
let's change it like done I like I we
walk out of the things like we're never
gonna do that podcast together I don't
want to talk to this person again or
whatever it is right whereas before it's
like
okay I have to sleep on it I have to
really think about it and like how am I
gonna it's like why do I care about how
I'm gonna say it this is what it is done
and it's just like that timeline is
compressed but the hardest one for me
like the first one was by far the
hardest and everyone since then the nice
thing is that no matter how difficult
your circumstance is if you have like
the bigger the wall that you have to get
through is as soon as you get past that
one big wall you then can use that wall
as the evidence for why you can jump
over the next well because that will be
the biggest one and so like after I did
quit my job and left my house and and
left Baltimore and didn't tell my dad
until I was across the country because I
was so afraid like people think of me as
like some big Alpha whatever dude I was
like I was such I was so afraid of my
father's disapproval that I didn't tell
him until I physically left the state
like like I'm not like think about that
like I wasn't even just one state over I
was like five states over and then I was
like hey by the way I'm going to
California and he was like well let's
come over we'll talk about it and I was
like I'm in Ohio already yeah yeah all
right you know then obviously he had a
different reaction but like but then
after that it was like what do I have to
do now it's like oh I gotta I gotta sell
strangers and I was like I told my dad I
didn't want to do what he wanted how
hard could this be
and so like it then becomes this one
huge proof point so the bigger the the
dragon is that you have to slay the more
evidence you have that you can say the
next dragon and I think that is if
there's ever been a good point for why
getting over the one first hard one is
so hard is that it will then give you
the reinforcement that you can do
whatever you need to do next yeah the
life you want is on the other side of a
few hard conversations and you're living
a life you hate because you're too
afraid to have them
I think about that a lot
because like whenever I feel anxious or
insecure or angry or sad I'm like what
conversation do I need to have that I'm
not having
and so then and usually if I just think
for not that long I'm like this is the
conversation I've been putting off and
then you know I'm not that the the the
poster child of mental health and so um
I'll just call myself a pansy for not
having the conversation and then and
then I just have it and so again I think
it's like I need to have this
conversation and the time between when I
have it versus or when I when I know I
need to have it when I actually have it
just because it continues to compress
and if you've ever had like a a breakup
or employee firing one of the or
acquitting if you're an employee like
these things that you dread
I don't know if you notice it but like
the day you do it the moment after you
do it I'm like how many other
conversations can I have like I want to
be like
yeah totally because it's a serial
killer for awkward conversations when I
so like the next series of hard
conversations that I had after I I've
left home was actually like years later
so I had I had multiple partners in my I
said I had a I had a partner in one of
my gyms I had a partner in four other
gyms I had a partner in a Cairo and
dental marketing agency and all of them
relied on me to make money
and so all of their livelihoods were
still dependent on me but I was
splitting everything and it was just it
was it was horrible for me at the time
and so I remember when I I ended up
getting in a DUI and you know I talked
to a a performance coach or whatever
and he was like your stress in these
conversations could literally kill you
he's like they almost did so I got a
head-on collision at 60 miles an hour
and I walked away no injuries
um but it was like my wake-up call but
not to stop drinking it was my wake-up
call that I needed to have these
conversations and that's what I was
avoiding when I was drinking it was in
the alcohols what were the things that
I'm avoiding that I'm using alcohol to
get away from and so
um the next day I had the first
conversation with the first partner and
it was horrible but the moment I was
done I was like I gotta call the other
guy and I called the other one I was
like this is how it is and the thing is
is I had this backstop of my death
of like you almost just died because you
wouldn't have this conversation and so
then it just gave me this courage to
just be like like and whatever the
reaction was I was like I'd rather be
alive
I think that was it and so it's it's
weird though because death has been this
really recurring theme in my life that
like the same thing happened when I was
it like the only thing that gave me
enough balls to stand up to my dad to be
fair from a distance from the car when I
was driving halfway across the country
like let's not make one let's not make
me any too big of a hero here
um was the idea that like I started
thinking like every day I was like I
hope I don't wake up you know what I
mean
um and that was the that was that was
the thing where I was like this is a big
enough problem that like if you don't
want to wake up then
what have you got to lose
exactly
and that was it and I was like I have
nothing to lose and that was when that
was when I think in the last podcast we
talked about this where it's like if
everybody who's like at the bottom and
feels like they have nothing going for
them
reframe that as I have nothing going for
me which also means that I have nothing
to lose by taking action it makes you a
much more dangerous person and I think
that was the flip that I've had
repeatedly shown to me in my life that
allowed me to take the step that I was
afraid to take if I told you about the
region beta Paradox have you seen that
one okay so this is interesting so
imagine that you had to go a Milo less
and if you did a mile a mile okay if you
had to travel a mile or less you would
walk it and if you had to go more than a
mile you would drive it okay so
paradoxically you would go two miles
quicker than you would go one mile
uh-huh
if you follow that rule the important
Insight here is that if you only take
action when things cross a certain
threshold of Badness sometimes better
things can feel worse than worse things
oh yeah so if you look around and you
see that people are stuck in region beta
this zone of comfortable complacency
right it's the guy that sticks and it's
just okay job because his boss isn't too
much of a dick but the pay isn't that
good and he's not really that passionate
but it's all right whatever whatever the
person that stays in the acceptable
relationship they're not that fired up
but they're not really in love and their
partner's not really got much alignment
with their interests or the person that
stays in a crappy apartment and there's
a bit of mold in the ceiling but it's
cheap and it's in a good area of town or
whatever all of these people would be
better off if their situations were
worse yeah because it would give them
the activation energy to kick them out
of the bottom and their only regret
would be not doing it sooner
did I love that
when I it was funny because if I look
back on the instances that were the most
painful in my life
every single one of them without fail
has created a disproportionate gain
right like the most painful thing early
on was for me was quitting my job and
leaving you know leaving my dad
basically and then that created
the you know my first my first business
in the gyms and all of that stuff
um you know getting into the DUI the
head-on collision
um and like that whole situation got me
out of all of these failed Partnerships
that I wasn't willing to do but in the
in the moment I was like I'm such a
failure like I suck at everything but
that gave me the springboard when I lost
everything the first time after that
um
that then gave me like the idea that I
needed to change the business model
around right and that's what switched me
into the licensing model right so like
each of these time and then that became
you know the the first this is kind of
like Alchemy yeah like turning something
which is worse than useless yeah into
something that's as precious and useful
as possible you know I'm sure you know
the parable of the you know the man in
the Sun and he like buys the Sun a horse
and then it falls and he breaks the leg
and then they're like oh it's so sad and
then the Army comes and the sun doesn't
die and then it's like oh so great right
and so it's one of those really
interesting ones where like whatever
negative situation and this is probably
good for the audience but like if you
think back to all the negative
situations yeah like the really really
bad ones when you expand the time
Horizon most times they become net wins
and so then it just means that like if
you're in a really tough time right now
you just gotta wait
and then you get and then you'll get
your reference point back on all the
things that change those result because
most times when [__] is bad it can't get
worse so then you feel like Well it
can't get worse than this and then your
action threshold decreases and you take
and you do all the things you know you
should have done anyways and so it's
like we have this big stack of should
do's and we just wait until it's two
miles yep and then you just you're like
you just get in the car like the firing
conversation and you're like well I just
fired one person or like I just ended
one partnership I just broke up with one
girl or whatever it is and you're like
who else do I need to talk to today
really like and then in like a period
like you have these rapid periods of
growth that happen and then you have the
next web of comfort because it's way
better than you were before and I think
it's I wonder this um this is more just
like an open thought but like I wonder
how long
like more successful people
stay in that next Plateau like I wonder
if their threshold for action but it
stays low yeah they're immediate like oh
like I'm getting Comfort like how
quickly they get comfortable into like I
need to change I need to get better
we'll get back to talking to Alex in one
minute but first I need to tell you
about element element is a tasty
electrolyte drink mix with everything
that you need and nothing that you don't
it's a healthy alternative to sugary
electrolyte drinks and it's how I've
started my morning every single day for
over three years you do not need to have
coffee first thing in the morning
because you're adenosine system that
caffeine acts on isn't even active but
your adrenal system is and salt acts on
your adrenal system element contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium that
helps to regulate appetite curb cravings
and improve your brain function but best
of all tastes phenomenal this orange
salt is unbelievable in a cold glass of
water first thing in the morning and
they have a no BS no questions asked
refund policy if you don't like it for
any reason they'll give you your money
back and you don't even need to return
the box that's how confident they are
that you'll love it head 2. drink
lmnt.com modern wisdom to get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box that's drink lmnt.com
modern wisdom
oh hey thanks for tuning in if you
enjoyed that clip then press here for
the full three hour podcast with Alex
go on
press it
[Music]